retrouvez manger ses voté
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à manger c'est beauté
au grand air comme toujours dans une
alternance de soleil et de brune
matinale on est en surplomb de la vallée
de la Loire ici sur les monts du Forez
cette chaîne de montagne qui sépare
l'Auvergne et Rhône-Alpes et on va
visiter ce département de la Loire en
compagnie de la sénatrice Cécile
buckermann du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste du Sénat
je la retrouve en bord de Loire un petit
peu plus bas à tout de suite
[Musique]
il descendent de la montagne mais à pied
je vois madame la sénatrice qui m'attend
bonjour bonjour
vous avez choisi un endroit merveilleux
Vincent Fernand bonjour
[Musique]
bienvenue dans les gorges de la Loire
ici en bout peut-être de notre
département de la Loire puisque nous
avons la Haute-Loire juste à côté juste
derrière et donc de ce fleuve Loire qui
n'en est qu'au début de sa traversée de
la France après un hiver assez sec
demeure encore assez bas dans cette
période on la remonte un petit peu cette
loi tranquillement
prof d'histoire-géo de profession
Cécile quierman vous vous cumulez deux
caractéristiques vous êtes à la fois une
femme et vous êtes dans le groupe
communiste est-ce que sont des avantages
ou des inconvénients alors écoutez je
vais rajouter une un troisième cumul si
vous me permettez mais qui maintenant
est passé parce que comme chacun je
prends une année chaque année qui fut
quand même en 2011 d'avoir été aussi la
plus jeune à ce moment-là le plus
difficile peut-être a été de se mettre
au diapason et compris de démontrer par
par son travail la capacité à être comme
tout un chacun dans tous les cas je
crois qu'il y a un vrai respect des uns
et des autres et d'une capacité à savoir
travailler ensemble
même la sénatrice qu'est-ce que ça
signifie aujourd'hui d'être communiste
en France et dans vos fonctions quel est
la part principale de votre engagement
elle se fait autour de quoi de l'humain
oui je crois que avant tout et surtout
c'est ça c'est ce combat pour l'égalité
pour une meilleure répartition des
richesses et finalement permettre à
chacun quel que soit sa condition
sociale sa condition territoriale
d'abord de pouvoir s'en émanciper et de
pouvoir construire sa vie et puis
collectivement de pouvoir toutes et tous
bien vivre je le dis parfois avec un peu
d'humour à certains collègues qui
peuvent être taquins mon objectif n'est
pas demain tout le monde devienne pauvre
mais que tout le monde devienne riche et
puisse vivre dignement mais est-ce que
le Sénat c'est le meilleur endroit je
suis avant tout et surtout une cicatrice
de la Loire et également
personnellement engagé aux parties
communistes français mais vous savez je
trouve toujours ça surprenant quand on
qualifie un élu d'abord par son
appartement politique plus que sa
circonscription parce que les résultats
électoraux les les rapports humains
dépassent bien évidemment simplement les
engagements politiques des uns et des
autres bon bah c'est vous mon guide pour
cette journée dans le monde agricole du
département de la Loire on y va nous
irons déjeuner à l'EHPAD de violet ou
nos anciens ont à disposition de la
bonne cuisine maison puis direction
l'art du cochon avec des porcelets
extrêmement joueurs vous verrez avant
une petite promenade sous les serres de
Julien lemaraicher puis dans les vignes
et la cave de Stéphanie Guillot allez en
route
[Musique]
dès qu'on quitte le fleuve loi ici on
monte on continue de monter sur les
hauteurs des du mont du Forez là on va
chez Alexis Masson qui fait de la fourme
fermière de Montbrison à fond la forme
allez
alors deux générations de producteurs
laitiers vous vous apportez tout votre
lait à la laiterie enfin il était
collecté donc vous ne fabriquez pas le
fromage
on a op juste pour la petite histoire
donc ça a été 30 ans de dur labeur parce
qu'il faut dire ce qui est être
agriculteur et livrer son laiterie c'est
pas toujours facile donc on a survécu
pour atteindre un bel objectif puisque
c'est l'installation d'Alexis qui est là
depuis 2019 a permis de prendre une
autorientation et vous vous n'aviez
jamais envisagé de faire de la
transformation
précédemment non alors nous on n'avait
jamais envisagé de faire de la
transformation il faut quand même savoir
que mon mari quand il s'est installé en
1988 lui il avait un poulailler
industriel c'est ce qui se faisait à
l'époque il faut quand même reconnaître
les choses l'agriculteur et ben il vit
avec son temps quoi alors il y a pas
meilleur valorisation dans la production
laitière que de faire du fromage et
notamment un fromage d'appellation et
jusqu'au bout du process parce que vous
ne faites pas seulement que de la
produire mais vous l'affinez également
dans la fine sur la ferme et on la vend
on fait les marchés donc voilà on va
vraiment au bout de la démarche tout le
forage que mange nos vaches l'hiver dans
le bâtiment et produit sur
l'exploitation donc on a de l'herbe
essentiellement de l'herbe qu'on récolte
de différentes manières en ensilage en
foin et puis on a on a un petit real
qu'on auto consomme aussi sur
l'exploitation
[Musique]
oh mais dites donc vos gouttières elles
sont en bois voilà les formes qu'on a
fabriqué cette semaine à la ferme on les
met dans cette pièce humide et chaude
sur ses genoux en bois justement donc
c'est du bois de résineux c'est
extraordinaire ça c'est-à-dire que dans
le cahier des charges de l'AOP il faut
qu'il y ait du bois du bois on se rend
compte que technologiquement c'est pas
faire ça quoi là c'est quand même laissé
une part de naturel qui n'est donc pas
contrôlable et donc voilà on a fini les
fourmis de moi dans la cave qu'on a fait
spécialement
ah super mais là c'est entièrement
couvert de briques là ça me maintient
mon ambiance dans la cave et cet Antoine
l'humidité il y a de l'eau partout là
donc on essaye d'avoir 95 d'humidité au
moins dans la cave quoi et donc dans une
fois mais il vous faut combien de litres
de lait ça varie en fonction de la
protéine qu'on a dans le lait et 10
litres de lait au kilo de fromage quoi
grosso modo grosso modo c'est ça sur une
fourme pour faire une fourme de 2 kg 2
kg 3 affiné quoi voilà une fois affiné
elle est à deux kilos 2 kg 3 d'où vient
cette couleur c'est la bactérie du rouge
comme on a sur un Maroilles par exemple
ces endothing ça vient de la Cheneau en
bois qu'on a vu tout à l'heure là on
voit le résultat du travail on voit que
les levures sont développées sur la
croûte qui ont la capacité de faire
orangir le fromage à la fin de la finage
c'est un fromage en or ouais c'est ça
c'est plaqué or ne vous dis pas le prix
oui bah si parlez moi du prix et ben un
kilo de fond de Montbrison affiné on le
vend à 17,90 voilà sur le marché c'est
le prix qui nous permet de de rembourser
nos prêts de vivre et de pouvoir
continuer à exploiter faire du fromage
quoi c'est tout ce qu'on vous souhaite
on peut voir que le bleu s'est développé
dans la fourme voilà pour le gros bouton
[Musique]
ça grimpe c'est si vous m'emmenez où là
dans le nord du département limite avec
le Rhône et nous arrivons à l'Ehpad ou
Michael le directeur Flavien le
cuisinier prépare chaque jour les repas
pour les résidents mais également pour
les enfants de l'école des repas qui
sont essentiellement travailler à partir
de produits locaux de produits bio
donc combien de temps le déjeuner chef
dans 5 minutes ouh là là
combien de convives ici à déjeuner dans
l'EHPAD 55 résidents nous avons qui
prennent l'ensemble de l'Europa donc
dans cette salle de restaurant qu'on les
repas également pour la cantine scolaire
qui est juste en bas du bâtiment
d'accord viennent manger sur place et
puis aussi chaque jour Fred livre des
repas à domicile sur la commune de
violet ah c'est Fred qui prend le vélo
et qui
super la vue du jambon dans les
assiettes là me donne envie d'aller en
cuisine c'est marrant je sais pas
pourquoi on peut monter à bord chef
alors là vous savez c'est les entrées
qui partent alors là chef je vois le
fameux jambon-beur mais on sait bien que
vos résidents n'ont pas la capacité de
couper de mâcher parfois j'ai fait une
entrée mixée d'accord salade avec des
petits pois mixés super et puis vous
faites ça ou des beautés comme ça tout
le temps puis alors on laisse le gras ça
pour moi c'est important
[Musique]
excellent
tout à fait
je serai pas venu pour rien
dis donc Michael de prendre de la viande
locale ça a un coup quand même dans
votre économie à l'Ehpad c'est un coup
oui forcément mais c'est important pour
nous de servir ce type de produit il
n'empêche que dans nos périodes
difficiles de d'augmentation des prix on
va dire et ben un vrai partenariat avec
des producteurs locaux s'avèrent très
positif parce que les prix augmentent
moins que sur d'autres fournisseurs on a
une vraie proximité des vrais liens en
fait vous avez envie de traiter vos
résidents comme vous traiteriez vos
parents tout à fait les parents les
enfants les personnes de la commune tout
le monde mérite d'avoir le meilleur
voilà qu'est-ce que vous mettez dans les
assiettes chef là bœuf bourguignon
carottes pour les mixer et le petit le
petit flan là c'est les légumes que les
autres mais passer à la moulinette
version mix on a ici un modèle qui
semble extrêmement vertu ça dépend aussi
de la personnalité du directeur cteur ou
de la directrice de l'établissement et
ses valeurs et sa volonté de
dans tous les sens de
la vie humaine fait que nous décidons de
ce que nous sommes nous sommes pas donc
effectivement oui le rôle des directeurs
le rôle des élus ont une influence
considérable sur ce qui se fait il se
fait pas l'incarnation humaine c'est
très important surtout au moment des
déjeuners moi je vais bien aller
incarner le restaurant au moment de
goûter ce bug bourguignon aussi il en
reste chef ok super on y va j'ai trop
faim maintenant
[Musique]
asso c'est très bonne
qui est très tendre ça bien mijoté parce
que tout ce qu'on dit c'est bien mais si
derrière ça suit pas une fois qu'on
déguste je peux désolé je me dépêche un
petit peu parce que je sais que vous
devez encore voir le scolaire madame
monsieur et moi on m'attend dans un
élevage de pores bio en plein air après
le bob c'est bien après le bob c'est
bien bonne continuation
Philippe Chorier oui bienvenue
l'art du cochon bio et là elle a RD
comme artiste comme de l'art on crée un
peu des choses donc c'est c'est cet
effet là ils sont où vos cochons alors
ils sont une partie ici vers le siège de
l'exploitation côté message avec les
mamans et j'ai aussi des parcs
extérieurs pour l'engraissement bon on
va voir les moments on est parti ah oui
j'aime bien voir
là je vois une belle femelle et elle est
bien suitée
après c'est une vieille mémère ça fait
déjà sa septième mise bas comment elle
s'appelle Stéphanie Fanny
oh belle soirée
alors il y a pas là tant qu'on embête
pas les petits il n'y a pas
l'agressivité mais elle aime bien se
faire frotter faire un câlin voilà quel
âge elle a cette truie
donc moi elles ont leur première
mise-bas environ un an et demi et après
c'est tous les 6 mois
là la truie elle est on peut dire Pompée
quand je la sève encore pendant 15 jours
3 semaines je lui donne bien à manger
pour qu'elle se requinque un peu qu'elle
refasse un peu du gras des réserves et
la reproduction c'est très facile on met
la truie avec le verra et trois quatre
jours après la truie revient en chaleur
il y a une saillie la gestation de la
truie est très facile à souvenir c'est
trois mois trois semaines trois jours
cochons on a un problème avec la peste
africaine porcine qui arrive dans
l'Italie
sont des porteurs donc ça arrive
d'Allemagne d'Italie donc
99% des cochons en France sont quand
même en bâtiment donc c'est simple on
ferme la porcherie à clé c'est
l'obligation
et nous en plein air il faut il nous
oblige à mettre des grillages j'adore un
grillage d'un mai 30 avec du courant à
l'extérieur pour le sanglier du courant
à l'intérieur et moi c'est quand je me
suis installé et j'ai valorisé des
terrains plats comme ici mais j'ai
beaucoup valorisé des battements et des
creux de vallée que personne voulait et
c'est un investissement énorme ça veut
dire qu'il faut clôturer partout 10
hectares avec une clôture d'un mètre
c'est un coup de combien c'est environ
70 000 euros et c'est surtout c'est pas
trop l'argent moi c'est le quoi c'est
l'argent mais c'est le travail quand
vous avez des pentes quand ces
mécanisables tu dis tu te fais un gros
chantier
tu appelles des clients des amapiens ils
viennent t'aider mais là
et puis avec des broussards
qu'est-ce qui se passe si vous le faites
pas et si je respecte pas c'est une
première amende de 1500 et après c'est
la fermeture de mon ah bon c'est ça le
risque mais si je comprends bien ce que
vous êtes en train de me dire Philippe
c'est qu'au fond on vous impose des
normes qui protègent le cochon
industriel au détriment d'exploitation
comme les vôtres qui sont
ultravertuses on compresse les petits en
plein air et on aide toujours le système
industriel les petits avec des systèmes
non représentatifs de qualité et bien
c'est bien plus compliqué on est
contrôlé alors c'est la dame elle fait
son travail moi il y a pas elle me met
en mise en demeure je lui dis bah
envoyez-moi bien les textes elle
m'envoie un texte de 65 pages ou faut
retrouver donc tu dis bah ouais tu l'as
trouvé mais moi j'aurais aimé plus
d'accompagnement tu vois de dire ben
compter il faut faire ça le chargement
hectare c'est tant toi là c'est
compliqué
[Musique]
alors là on est ouvert sur l'extérieur
pour que le vent rentre séchoir naturel
mais les saucissons ils sont au four
[Musique]
c'est beau ça sent bon la fleur là c'est
la fleur là après au mois de on a eu de
l'humidité un peu donc il y a eu bien
une bonne fleur là naturel c'est une
petite des petits champignons une petite
position tout à fait c'est ce qui donne
le goût et c'est ce que font pas les
industriels qui mettent souvent de la
farine de riz voilà dessus presque qui
est le goût moi je dirais il y a la
viande il y a la recette et le séchoir
c'est divisé en 3 on goûte ensemble
on voit qu'elle est qu'elle a foncé
merci beaucoup Philippe merci de cette
visite et du saucisson je vais le garder
parce que je voudrais le faire goûter à
la scène d'être ici et d'ailleurs je me
ferai le porte-parole de l'agriculture
bio parce que franchement cette histoire
de clôture là pour garder vos cochons on
marche sur la tête je vais lui redire
merci merci à bientôt
[Musique]
je vous ai apporté du saucisson merci on
va chez le maraîcher là
[Musique]
je vais vivre un truc assez insensé
Cécile je vous le dis carrément vous
avez raté un truc voilà un producteur
bio de cochon
extensifs à qui on demande de mettre des
clôtures autour de 10 hectares il a pas
les moyens cet homme-là malheureusement
ce n'est pas que sur cette exploitation
et ce n'est pas un cas unique je crois
qu'on a effectivement une vision de
l'accompagnement du développement du
monde agricole aujourd'hui qui est assez
standardisé et qui finalement tombe à
nier la spécificité de ces petites
exploitations ceux qui veulent continuer
d'avoir une agriculture à taille humaine
oui j'entends bien mais enfin on croit
rêver on marche sur la tête on demande
au petit de payer pour les gros et tout
ça pour bouffer de la merde non mais non
non
bonjour bonjour
avec plaisir bienvenue Julien on peut
aller voir les légumes moi je vous
propose avant d'aller voir les légumes
d'aller voir mon frigo bio frigo bio il
est là ça existe un frigo bio regarde
la porte
on enlève un peu de terre
un peu de fougère oh là là et les
betteraves tout l'hiver ils l'ont passé
dans la terre
jusqu'au mois de juin là il y a les
radis noirs vous pouvez toucher elles
sont encore ferme ils sont humides elles
sont pas mangées par les souris
donc un mélange de fougère et de paille
c'est un ancien maraîcher qui m'a
expliqué l'astuce du coup j'ai vraiment
pas de chambre froide pour l'instant
j'ai qu'un gros frigo mais ma chambre
froide elle est là et on était on peut
s'en servir encore et on était aussi
alors faut pas que la terre soit trop
chaude là ça marche surtout pour les
légumes racines les rats quoi voilà les
légumes racines ça marche très bien le
fil
de 10 hectares avec une partie en
légumes un hectare et demi de légumes
j'ai quatre cerfs et les presque 9
hectares qui restent c'est quoi c'est de
la prairie pour du foin donc on a un
accord avec un éleveur donc il met ses
vaches puis moi il me donne du fumier en
échange il vient les pendre donc cette
fumure vous aurez besoin évidemment pour
l'engrais naturel voilà on peut aller
voir aussi
alors qu'est-ce qu'on trouve ici il y a
de l'oignon là
au bout de leur tête voilà il commence à
être formé là ils vont pas tarder 15
jours 3 semaines ils sont prêts la
gestion de l'eau c'est un vrai souci ou
j'ai la chance d'avoir une borne
d'irrigation donc du canal du Forex qui
prend l'eau dans le fleuve Loire mais il
y a court terme il y a des restrictions
et donc
on s'adapte on essaye de pailler on
essaye de mettre des toiles pour essayer
d'avoir conserver le plus l'eau possible
le rapport
à le changer dans les pratiques on
réduit on choisit peut-être des espèces
un peu moins
gourmandes
de la profession il y avait avant des
gens un peu rêveurs qui s'installaient
en se disant on se contentera de l'eau
du ciel mais là non maréchal
dans le mur on peut pas faire sans eau
c'est plein d'eau enfin c'est 80 90%
d'eau donc on a besoin d'eau il y a pas
de miracle quel genre de circuit de
distribution vous utilisez je suis à 80
90% en vente directe et puis vous avez
du vous avez une clientèle qui est super
fidèle en fait après c'est une question
de confiance c'est vrai que
alors moi je les ai fidélisés j'ai les
mails près de tous mes clients je leur
envoie chaque semaine la liste avec les
prix et tout mais
ouais c'est vraiment une question de
confiance et ils peuvent venir ici j'ai
quelques clients qui viennent le samedi
matin prendre vers les légumes
directement ici ils savent comment je
travaille c'est merci Julien de rien
merci
à vous on vous souhaite de la pluie
le frigo naturel les légumes dans la
terre qui est le merveille on va où
maintenant on va chez Stéphanie Guillot
vigneronne dans les codes du foret qui
fut la première vigneronne à s'installer
[Musique]
bonjour
Stéphanie Vincent bonjour Stéphanie
merci de recevoir dans vos vignes et
qu'est-ce que c'est comme cépage là on
est sur la partie gamète parce que plus
haut c'est pas pareil c'est du chardonné
dans les mêmes rangs vous avez du
Chardonnay vous passez aux gamins oui
c'est mon propriétaire et il a eu cette
idée de mettre un petit peu de gamelle
d'un côté et pour le haut du Chardonnay
alors lorsqu'on regarde le terrain ici
sous-sol granitique et on comprend bien
avec cette pente douce que c'est un
terrain qui est extrêmement drainé
exactement donc c'est les anciens
glaciers qui ont fait rouler sur le sol
donc ça a désagrégé tout doucement
qui est souple d'accord
non mais on sent la texture des petits
graviers en fait de granit on sait
jamais trop où situer la Loire et donc
plus on aura de produits de spécialités
qui nous permettent finalement de
l'entrée de la marque géographiquement
plus il y aura en tout cas de
reconnaissance pour celles et ceux qui
qui produisent ces bons produits
Stéphanie je sais qu'ici c'est un coteau
ou parfois le climat est rude vous avez
subi la graine l'an dernier beaucoup oui
j'ai gré les trois fois cette année
trois fois le 22 juin où j'ai perdu
trois hectares ou 100% a été dedans et
la veille des vendanges sur cette partie
là en septembre oui le 7 septembre 2022
les morceaux de feuilles étaient par
terre il y avait des graines par terre
des morceaux de raisin par terre les
baies étaient éclatés donc il y avait
des oxydations qui étaient en cours
ça fera comment tout le travail d'une
année qui qui voilà qui part combien
vous avez perdu de de récolte là dessus
sur ma déclaration de récolte j'ai moins
50% voilà c'est par rapport à une
normale moins 50% la moitié était par
terre
ça va se lisser sur plusieurs années
écoutez si vous en reste assez moi
j'aimerais bien mettre le nez dans le
verre
on va à la cave
[Musique]
c'est un vin qui est entre le Bourgogne
et le Côtes du Rhône c'est à dire avec
assez peu de tanins en définitive et une
bonne acidité qui est le sous-titan quoi
en quelque sorte
une très bonne analyse
à mon tour de vous emmener
au cuisine on est à Saint-Galmier et on
va voir Antoine Bergeron le chef de la
Charpinière chef jeune et étoilé Antoine
on s'en remet à la cuisine de la
sénatrice
du porc j'ai choisi du million de porc
et on va travailler ça donc avec légumes
assez simple sur les légumes de saison
carottes oignons un petit peu de côtes
du foret et régional de l'étape la forme
de Montbrison
[Musique]
elle est belle
est-ce qu'au fond dans le travail du
sénateur de la sénatrice il y a pas en
filigrane l'écologie je rappelle
je ne connais aucun élu dont l'objectif
c'est de détruire le territoire communal
les sénateurs nous sommes de cette
écologie qui préserve son environnement
mais qui n'oublie pas une chose c'est
qu'un environnement il est sain parce
que l'homme peut y vivre et parce que
l'homme l'aménage donc je crois qu'on a
besoin de toujours rester vigilant de
continuer à la fois d'accompagner le
paysan mais aussi d'accompagner le
consommateur pour pouvoir faire la
démonstration que bien manger consommer
local c'est sans pour lui ce n'est pas
forcément toujours beaucoup plus cher et
cela permet d'avoir une retombée direct
qui font vivre des paysans sur sur notre
territoire dans notre pays et puis
effectivement mais ça c'est un choix
politique que j'avais défendu et que je
continuerai de défendre qui est comment
est-ce que on réduit les marges et les
intermédiaires qui finalement ne rendent
service aujourd'hui ni aux paysans on
amont de la chaîne ni aux consommateurs
à la sortie de la chaîne
magnifique c'est beau ça et ça sent bon
la question rituel et qu'est-ce qu'on
boit avec ça un code du foret ah bah non
un verbe Badoit quand même c'est pour le
côté
la source est à 300 mètres on peut aussi
et puis ça c'est sans modération comme
l'émission que vous pouvez retrouver sur
Public Sénat à bientôt
[Musique]
c'était manger c'est voté avec Mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires
[Musique]